you look a bit like me
good twins he was so friendly so nice
so funny so handsome it's just
life's friends yeah literally he was
kobe shouldn't have taken him so early
it was so horrible people just need to
be careful because we didn't do anything
but that took him to us and yet he's
still home twice
on thursday maya and her sisters
lost their grandad ken to the virus
in march it almost took their dad's life
too darren was in
intensive care and given 15 minutes
to call his family and say goodbye
seeing ken um brought back some awful
memories
i probably didn't realize how bad i was
back in march
and um it was so upsetting seeing him
trying to fight to live fight for breath
um angela was nursing him like a nurse
would
um in the last few hours and she should
be very proud of that
angela ken's daughter was allowed onto
the ward
after his condition deteriorated but he
didn't realise how bad he was
and he couldn't tolerate having the mask
on and having oxygen being forced into
his body so when they called me in they
call me in to basically tell me
that he couldn't do it anymore and that
it was
his wishes we need to be mindful of
now so and then he was taken to
another ward then to to die
ken's family want covert deniers
to listen to their story it is real
it's really disappointing and
frustrating that people think it isn't
they should just spend five minutes on a
hospital board and see those people
fighting for their life fighting for
breath alone
no dignity the nursing staff caring for
them like they were their loved ones
it's not nice to see darren is donating
his blood to
covid research at first motivated by his
own survival
now by his father-in-law's death
lisa dowd sky news staffordshire